choosing the right business partner
could make or break you today we're
gonna talk about ten different types of
business partners solo choosing a
business partners very is similar to
dating you don't just kind of make a
decision and say I want to marry this
person because in a way your business
partner your credits are tied
you're gonna see each other regularly
there's a lot of different things that
you're tied to each other whether this
is gonna work out or not money just like
marriages you know there's a different
story between dating and you tell people
this is my girlfriend this is my
boyfriend versus this is my wife woman
have kids with so if you're gonna build
a business with somebody it's very
important to know different kind of
business partners and what to do about
it at the beginning stages of it so you
don't have long term conflicts let me
get right into it first kind of business
part you may have as a leaner somebody
that you and him or you and her we're
talking you felt good about this working
out for you but then this person is
constantly leaning on you to grow the
business and they're not I get calls
regularly from people that say my
brother leans on me I do all the work he
doesn't do nothing you know my friend
and I started a business at the
beginning he worked very hard the first
six months last six months we've been
making money I don't see him at the
office he comes he leaves he relies on
me to do because he says you said you
wanted to be the CEO you said you wanted
to be the face so you do all this stuff
and I'm just here on the side right
that's the Leonard so then there's a
bank the guy that's the bank is somebody
that puts in the money and says look I
give you the money you go figure things
out and say well is it kind of like a
business partnership not really I'm just
giving you the money you gonna make the
business work are you gonna help me a
little bit nope it's the bunny you go do
what you got to do so that's the bank
relationship with you when you're
working with somebody that's to make the
next one is the boss the boss says used
to be your friend you guys used to be
buddies maybe you went to college to get
all of a sudden you start a business
he's kind of Boston yeah you need to do
this I need you to do this have you done
this year do we get to see in like wait
a minute why are you bossing me around
and how do you handle a situation like
that you know I'm the one that runs the
show here that's the position I have
here yeah but you we're friends so
there's kind of a conflict on how to
handle that next one is a guilt trip
guilt trip is funny because let's just
say you're the single one he's the
married with kids but you started a
company together and at the beginning
like we're gonna go lights-out we're
gonna go make this work I get it up I'm
all in and he had family he had kids at
the time and you didn't and he makes you
feel guilty is like you know what I I
haven't seen them I got to go home and
it's four o'clock like I got to go home
today
two o'clock he's leaving early and he's
giving you areas of guilt that you don't
know how to handle because you're single
that person is guilty you can't well we
started this business to get ya but you
know you know my family my kids and you
don't know how to handle a situation
like this you're kind of mobilized
you're stuck and internally you're
ticked off at the guy but you don't know
what to say to the person next one is a
bottom line or the ATM guy let me
explain to you this is this is somebody
where you know it's too much of a black
and white situation there is no gray
area like hey we did this if we make
money or didn't wait make money so it's
tough to talk to them in marketing
because they're all of our bottom line
and anytime money is made the profit
comes out quickly someone you're like
let's reinvest and think about what this
could work well is it gonna make us
money or not it's yeah I don't know yet
we may we may not know let's just take
the profits out so it's a bottom line
type of personality next one is a
machine-gun Tommy this is somebody that
uses your past mistakes over and over
and over and over on you well you're
kind of like oh my gosh if I hear have
to have that be held over me again it's
gonna drive me nuts but when that
happens it's a tough environment to be
in next one is pansies what I mean by
pansies the moment the company is having
some tough times and something could
happen that could break or somebody
quits or resigns or a partner they crank
totally crack and they bring them morale
down because they're your partner but
they're going on seeing what's gonna
happen oh my gosh what if we go out of
business and people that were okay just
doing their business go lower because
this person doesn't know how to handle
pressure the next one is loose lips
loose lips is somebody that maybe does
their work they're good people they're
not trying to hurt you they just can't
help themselves with sharing the
information with everybody so imagine
somebody who's loose lips you got an
environment he's a partner he goes home
tells his wife everything his wife goes
and has dinner with the other wise and
she tells them everything and the next
thing you know it comes back to you how
did you say that to anybody I didn't
tell it to anybody I was just talking to
my wife maybe some of the stuff you
shouldn't even talk to your wife about
but I can't help myself my wife to do
then that could be to people at the
environment
and they're not doing it intentionally
to hurt you they just can't help
themselves but that's somebody that
could be a business partner next one is
a band-aid band-aid is somebody that
everything is just about short-term fix
yet you know we got to spend a hundred
thousand or two thousand let you spend
two thousand we got to spend fifty
dollars or five thousand dollars just do
this just do the $50 job everything is
that years ago I had my s600 I took her
to dealership and my dad had a guy that
was known in a Middle Eastern community
so he said take it to this guy took it
to this guy and he says well I fix it he
took $4,600 from me I gave it to him at
a time okay I don't want to give you
4600 uh but I give him $4,600 then I
take you to the dealership to sell the
car he says sir can you come over here
please I said what's that he says let me
show you this right here he lives the
car up he says who did you pay money to
fix this I'm like somebody that was
referred to my dad that was a family
friend he says this is what the guy did
he didn't do any job for you he just did
a quick vist this cost $50 to make I
said how much he said $50 I called the
guy out make sure everybody knew to
never do business with this guy and he
didn't end up getting the clientele the
big book of business that he was about
to get he lost all of it because he was
a band-aid guy there's a lot of Bandi
type of people in businesses which
eventually hurts the business big time
because reputation spreads next one is
strategic strategic is somebody that
looks at you and says that's pure logic
I think if I strategically pardon myself
with this guy this could be a great
person to leverage because it could help
in different areas help my business out
so this is actually not a bad thing this
could be a good thing but it's logical
strategic partnership that could get
results in maybe different areas of
their lives and it may not be fully -
let's just build this it may be other
areas to help them win in life as well
maybe some other items that they're
working on that this thing's gonna help
that as well so look you may be watching
this right now saying oh my gosh that
reminds me of Johnny that's Bobby this
is later let me share this text with the
people we worked at who does this person
remind you of that guy was a pansy that
guy was a loose lips that guy was the
ATM that guy was a leaner of fine it may
be true but let me give you an idea why
this takes place many times many times
this takes place because when there is
conflict or there's an issue the famous
three things that people do is either
they fight they for
right or they freeze happens which means
what when there is a flight means oh my
gosh
this didn't work out this is top boom
you run away from the problem yeah it's
normal supposed to be happening but you
run away flight freezes oh my gosh I
just figured out how this person is this
person keeps doing this to me and
they're bossing me right you don't do
nothing about it you freeze or there's
fight you sit down and have a
conversation because you know what I
just said fight flight freeze was
written in a book called crucial
accountability and Crucial Conversations
great books but the other one is from
five dysfunctions of a team Patrick
Lencioni breaks it down in the best way
at the bottom of any of these issues you
may have you with your business partner
its absence of trust you don't trust
your partner who's the boss you don't
trust your partner who's a bottom-line
atm you don't have a certain level of
trust or they don't trust you their
trust is both ways so if you don't sit
down and address that nothing's gonna be
fixed so in order when there's absence
of trust that leads to fear of conflict
then there is no commitment there is no
accountability then it's a inattention
to result then the company's going down
so what do you have to do at the
beginning if there is an opportunity
where you lack trust in them or they
like trust in you you got to have the
conversation with them and then have the
issue once you address them you bring up
the complicate John what's that I feel
like you're bossing me around really
wouldn't mean a boss in your I don't
boss you around yeah you boss me around
let me just tell you what you did last
five times listen man we started off
this thing was exciting but you've been
up you went from a friend to a boss now
and I don't like that it's really bother
me I missed this guy before by the way
I've had many of these conversations
with people before right and then you
either sitting there like wow this guy's
got a point that person's got a point
it used to be this and used to be that I
mean this person's got a point
that person's got a point you can't
handle the pressure oh my gosh maybe I'm
a short-term thinker and then you give
your illustration and you explain it to
them and it may get heated but the only
way you're gonna resolve these issues is
to have that conflict because once you
have the conflict and you have the
conversation with them guess how the
conversation ends here's how it ends
it's either gonna end screw you to hell
with you I can't believe you took this
approach and even if you were just being
very gentle about it I can't believe you
took this approach and then they may go
settle down the next thing they're gonna
come back and they're gonna say look
about her last night oh yeah what
happened can we talk yellow stuck I
think you're right and a couple of
things and I wasn't too happy about you
bringing it up but III want to make this
work okay what do you want to do I want
to make this work
so what are you willing to commit to I'm
willing to commit to dot dot dot perfect
and then I need you to do this as well
because they're gonna ask you to I need
you to come into that that that you
always put the family guilt over me and
I don't like it you go home early
great I'll work on that as well so how
about we put a schedule to get an
understanding together no problem see
then there is commitment from both sides
to each other then there is a level of
accountability and then you start paying
attention to results and then the
company starts growing this is a thing
that it's very common I didn't make this
video for you to go out and get upset at
your business partner I made this video
for you to address the trust issue with
each other and understand the conflict
as a part of growing a business now if
you haven't yet started a business if
you haven't yet started a company it's
like if you haven't yet gotten married
why not you got enough data to make sure
you know to do it right before you
decide to make the next step of creating
a business partner teaming up with
somebody because now you have the
information by the way one of the most
common questions I get asked is the
following is a pot Pat how do i how do I
choose the right business partner as
well as how do I work with family and
business I have a video for each one of
these okay so if it's how to choose a
business partner click on this one if
it's how to work with your family in
business click on this one I have
experience with both and I share my
insight with you on how I address it
both of these videos can help you know
if you haven't yet subscribe to the
channel yet please do so click on our
link below here take everybody bye-bye
you
[Music]